what came to this video playing sv
something we hi love as me my love from
from norway norwegian flag but we have
many norway players here i think it's
due to all these reasons people like to
be associated with Norway ok let's save
let's play castles get us an interesting
line ever done that in my my book my
analysis let's see can I do something
else I most they have d5 in my my book
here but don't let's try for wow this is
this is dull immediately looking for the
trade ok well I play some some dull
lines myself so must be careful and play
our Kings Kings Indian exchange and
stuff check ok this is however very very
modest for might I go here because I
want to play a quick f6 and the night of
course wants to go to c5 and b6 deserve
crucial squares to a métis weekend
coincide of b3 and ce4 those are weak
and something that gives me some hope to
maybe even get get a really good game
out of this f5 yeah let's fix this for a
moment yeah the issue is wow this is a
big concession
hmm hard to say various good ideas that
let's let's just improve a bit i'm not
i'm not sure how to exchange here
properly can I take on v3m knight takes
Bishop see phone
it's very close
come on let's go for that if it's not
working whatever it's a bit of a shame
in it it would be a bit of a shame if it
is not working because with purely
strategical means i would have had an
excellent position but it seems to it
seems to be okay i also have porn if all
I don't really see a movie I look a 4 I
can try oh I didn't think about that one
at all
yeah still eform rook a form for the
asus very good efore Bishop takes Knight
x at x rocker and it doesn't have a good
square so on yeah he doesn't have a move
here no no move at all p for sir the big
problem Bishop takes Knight takes it
takes the rook and it doesn't have a
good square yes so but what are you
supposed to do is black hard too hard to
not take only form
yeah I can barely move or PCM
yeah yeah I was briefly considering this
you wondering you know I can I just
click you can just play a ship push it
back in yeah okay that's not I'm already
a bit behind on the clock zone try to be
a bit quick can take on c5 with the rook
but yeah I can just take it III at the
NC 5
yeah he's falling behind on the clock so
this is this is a good sign that I don't
get into some some big-time issues later
okay how do i play now I can also take a
form and let's grab him there's also a
for hanging so he needs to take care
about that take care about them take
care of that no not about take care off
yeah there's no way to really a cabaret
form and you don't have any any good
moves anyway yeah I think they exchange
only five and in this particular case
isn't a good idea because as Queen side
is weak and the sum was used with the
sacrifice even in this game with night
xb3 yeah he's not coming up with the
move anymore yeah maybe slightly
frustrated i have this scoring function
at the beginning of the game enter he's
got really terrible scoring and sleeping
so okay Bishop e3 may be intending to
take d2 and promote
you could have taken on d3x I'm
hmm
okay well I'm going to win on time so
some it's not necessary to play perfect
moves okay come on channel keep it keep
it simple check check yeah I've got
these got the check I capture whoopsie
form was my idea of the slip and I
forgot about that check hmm no I get it
white resigns yeah the it really came
down to the opening him I think this is
a battery to this setup because look at
this this is all very weak already and
the bishop on g2 is just biting on the
six pawn that is about to be toasted
them and now we just is in trouble the
pawns are just weak the computer already
gives us a winning minus two amazing
with that bd7 actually but ok this isn't
bad at all i keep I keep keeping echium
here Bishop f5 is also good Bishop f5
intending Bishop c2 but ok what I did
was was perfectly ok I think and yeah
well i don't know i don't need to
sacrifice but it's interesting yeah the
computer says is winning ok this is
assuring now he falls maybe even
stronger but yeah here there are
multiple ways to win the important thing
is to take note of the exchange which is
really bad because those pawns get to be
a weakness even with the bishop
defending it let's say the bishop would
be here it's not great but it's it's
very one-sided
black doesn't have any weakness at all I
played the night f.2d 7 the night f 37
so that I can always play f6 to protect
a 5 this is the only potential weak spot
of light play something like this which
is ok you can oops quickly go here then
at least with this kind of setup you
sometimes need to worry about the pawn
but in this position with the night here
it's even know no pressure on this pawn
so very one-sided game that that
occurred here thanks for watching